Welcome back. We have just seen
some simple examples of the I/O monad
that allows a Haskell program to
communicate with the outside world.
And the idiom
that we emphasized was that we have
a sea of imperative code with
islands of pure code.
In this part of this lecture
we are going to show a slightly larger
example
that also features this pattern.
We will have some imperative code
that glues the program that we are
going to write, the pure program that
we are going to write, with the outside
world.
But we are going to use all the nice
functions
pure functions that we defined before
over lists
we are going to use them here to
write the core of our program.
The example that we are going to do is a
very simple
version of the game of hangman.
If you have never played hangman, it's
a popular game with kids
and what you do is one person
has a secret typed word and then the
other person
has to try to guess the word by
entering a sequence of guesses.
And for each guess, you will
see which letters occur
and then as you go on, you have
to guess the word.
Kids play this quite a lot and it's
kind of fun.
The hangman part is that you only have
a finite number of
tries and you draw a picture and
at some point you die
because you
ran out of turns. So the game ends
when the word is correct. In this case
we don't draw pictures or try to
make you lose.
Now let's
start writing this code.
What we are going to do, is we are
going to take a top-down approach
where as we go we will design the
parts of the game that we need.
But we first start with the interaction
with the outside world.
What we do is we print to the output
"Think of a word" and then we
secretly read that word.
This function sgetLine
will read a string, but it will
echo that string with underscores.
And then
the computer will ask us to try to
guess the word.
How do we do that? Well, we typed
in the word
and then we are going to guess the
word and
we will see what that function guess is
in the next few slides. First thing I
want to show
is this function here
sgetLine, which reads a line of
text from the keyboard
echoing each character as a dash, as
an underscore.
So what do we do? Well, it's a function
that reads a string from the standard
input, so it has type IO String and
what do we do?
We first get the character.
If that character is a newline
then we echo the newline
and then we return the empty string.
Otherwise
we print an underscore
we recursively secretly read
the rest of the string and then we
return
the string that we read.
You can type this code in and try
it out in GHCi. And what you will see
is that as you type a word, it will show
the dashes and it will return
the word that you typed in, without
revealing
what the word was, because it only shows
you how many characters there are.
The action getCh here
reads a character
without echoing it to the screen.
So what we have to do
is we have to turn the echoing off
then we read a character and then
we turn the echoing on
and then we actually return the
character. So here you see
that this is typical imperative code
where you write one statement, another
statement, another statement
another statement, and one thing to note
is that while this looks like an
assignment
it is really not an assignment.
This is just saying
this is type IO of Char and you bind it
to a character. So there are side effects
here
because we are interacting with the
environment
but we are not using mutable variables.
Haskell does support mutable variables
but we won't discuss them
in this lecture. But for that you have to
have a special monad or you can do it
in the I/O monad as well, but you have to
allocate specifically the mutable variables
and write and read from them. And this
here, because this is a monad
it just takes the value of this computation
and binds it to c. So c is not a mutable
variable.
Enough of the I/O part. Let's now
look at the function guess. Guess is
the game loop, which requests
guesses and then checks whether the
guesses are right
until the user
or the player has found the right answer.
Let's look at the code. We guess the word.
This word was the secret word that
we read.
So what we do is we print
a prompt on the screen, we
read the guess, and then if the word that
we typed in was the secret word
we are done.
So we say: Congratulations, you got it!
Otherwise we
compute the difference between the secret
word
and what the user typed in
we print that difference on the standard
output
and we then recursively go
and guess the word. And here you see
where there is a tail recursion.
This thing here "guess word"
calls "guess word" again and if you are a
lousy player
like me, you will have to use a lot of
turns
to do this and you don't want this
to stack overflow.
And...
We are now back
into the world of pure functions. We
finally left the sea
of imperative code and we have reached
the beautiful island
of purity. And there we are going to
define this function "diff".
The function that takes two strings
and returns a string that
describes their difference.
To define that function we are going to
use a list comprehension.
So what we say
we take the two strings and we are going
to check
for each character in the first string
for each x
in the first string, we say
if that character
appears in the second string, then
we just return that character. So every
character
from the first string that appears in
the second string, we are just
going to return
and all characters from the first string
that don't appear in the second string
we are going to return an underscore. So
for example: if we take the diff between
"haskell"
and "pascal" then we see that
the as
appears here and the double l
appears here, because l appears there.
But we see it twice, because we just look
whether
l appears in this string, yes, and then
we see another l
that appears here as well. So it's a
very simple diff. It just checks which
strings on the left appear on the right.
That was the whole game. Happy
hacking and make sure again
that you do your exercises
and that you play around with the I/O
monad and when you write code yourself
no matter whether it's Haskell, C#
Java, F#, Scala, Python, PHP
think about the idea of having a sea
of imperative code that interacts with the
outside world
and in there have islands of pure code
where you write your functions in a
pure way.
But you have to decide how big the
islands are
and how big the sea is. But the answer
is never that there are only islands
or only sea. A good programmer knows
exactly the right balance. Great!
Thank you and see you next time.